yo yo let me tell y'all something I mean
this sincerely Prince Harry and Megan we
don't give a [ __ ] America don't give a
[ __ ] about you a lot of people care we
don't care about the royal family you
never cared about nothing that had to do
with y'all
1775 was the last time we gave a [ __ ]
you don't even give him the whole year
you don't even give him for that whole
year we cared yeah because we were like
are we still gonna be part of it but
1776 came around we didn't give a flying
[ __ ] about y'all keep your shows keep
your drama keep all that nonsense that's
for you British people to fake care
about we do not give a [ __ ] we don't
care baby fake care day [ __ ] fake
cast I want to hear the gossip I'm the
only one that wants to hear what comes
out in this book that's that British
that's not British on Indian people they
[ __ ] that inside
you're British I'm from Scotland you're
British bro that's the most [ __ ] up
[ __ ] I saw
hey hold up hold up hold on hold on
I was like we're getting different
weapons
well you better watch out now how big is
that dick you just jerked off
we don't care about we don't care about
Megan we don't care about Harry yeah
that was that might have been Indian
thing bro India's got some pretty
Traditions yo yeah we're gonna get to
that one in a second but hold on hold on
yeah that's a great story well then
we're gonna get to that one in a second
but just to clear up this hairy Mega
[ __ ] yeah yeah okay you explain okay we
don't care about y'all we don't gossip
about it
be like [ __ ] on people that we don't
like yeah they think they're important
yeah you know that is true first of all
Harry and Megan are the wackers
[ __ ] because they really don't
realize that people don't care about
them like they moved to montesino like
this is the fancy part of Santa Barbara
right and they were like renting out the
restaurants and being like it just needs
to be just us when we go out to eat here
y'all are broke
y'all got no money British guy with red
hair I got no money you think people
think that he's Ed Sheeran I think
that's what he's afraid of yeah he's
afraid of red guy yes but British accent
walks around they're gonna think I'm
[ __ ] Ed Sheeran exact thing yo that's
great he's being mistaken yeah that
[ __ ] is mistaken if he walks
around security we think he's someone
else the best kid's gonna get his
Santino so
[Laughter]
it's not a character he could actually
play Yeah his episode ain't out yet they
don't even know yeah yeah eventually
yeah it will eventually be out Santino
is more famous than uh Harry that's
right Santino is more known than Harry
that's definitely not this literally
I can't pick out I can't pick out Harry
on the street
exactly Harry had a podcast I think that
he had a fire joke bro yeah this this
Nazi joke he did oh yeah on Halloween
one time yeah yeah that's all that Nazi
yeah you saw that was awesome that was
crazy right that was crazy
yeah he tried to play he tried to blame
it on William and uh Kate yeah yeah yeah
what'd he say I don't know
I just read the headline the audiobook
didn't come out yeah
he's gonna read it in British yeah I
know anything about this [ __ ] because I
really don't I know I know a few things
okay so basically dressed up as Nazi and
he said that they like encouraged him to
do it and it was like uh it was like an
Africa party or whatever or it's like a
like yeah it was basically Africa party
and he dressed up as like a Nazi General
that went to Africa or something so he's
like I wasn't Hitler I was a good Nazi I
mean the Nazis did go to Africa and they
encouraged me to be this guy blah blah
blah and that like Nabi that that's what
he claimed apparently how old was he I
don't know I think it was like late or
like 20s what else he said he said he
killed 25 Talent man yeah he called it
Knocking chess pieces off a board yeah
that's kind of fire to be honest with
you but like that how do you kill him
yeah you think he like with a gunshot I
don't think they're putting him in the
position where he could be shot maybe
he's a sniper
maybe he's a sniper train sniper maybe
his cap
maybe he busted a cap no maybe his cat
he'd kill no 25 Taliban [ __ ] why
would he lie about that why would he lie
about so did we talk about it lying
about killing people